bruno m'égare ban bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors pour commencer il ya eu
ce matin cette mise en garde est
ministre de la santé concernant un sou
variant de mikron le béa deux ils
pourraient contaminer d'après ce qu'on
nous dit qu'est ce que l'on sait
vraiment aujourd'hui de se souvenir y en
ait coûté
contrairement aux prévisions initiales
les contaminations en france comme au
danemark ne semble pas décroître
et donc on a constaté qu'un nouveau
variant un sou variant de mikron omikron
classique que l'on appelle la b1 et bien
souvent rien à b 2 semble exister alors
au danemark il a été il est désormais
majoritaire et pourrait peut-être
expliquer le fait que les contaminations
progresse ce variant a été
essentiellement identifiés en asie du
sud est il est il semble plus contagieux
que la souche originel au ab1 néanmoins
il n'est pas associé à une virulence
supplémentaires par contre on ne sait
pas aujourd'hui est ce que le fait
d'avoir été contaminés par ab1
confère une immunité suffisante pour ne
pas être recomptés miné par un v2 est
donc évidemment il pourrait expliquer
une prolongation
de
l'épidémie omicron notamment dans les
pays où ce variant s'est installée et
progress un sou vaillant qui résistera à
la vaccination
alors la vaccination on protège contre
les formes graves de la maladie quelle
que soit le vario qu'il soit
le variant historique chinois le variant
britannique sud africain où le variant
delta ou omicron à b1 et la b2 donc il
n'ya pas de crainte là dessus à
condition bien sûr d'avoir reçu les deux
doses et la dose de rappel al'inverse
bien sûr comme vous le savez la
vaccination semble un tout petit peu
moins efficace que ce que l'on pensait
concernant le risque de contamination
même s'il le réduit de 3 par rapport aux
sujets non vaccinés alors malgré les
mesures qui ont été prises vague omicron
vous nous lie un tarda à reflux en
france avec des chiffres encore très
élevé les plus élevés d'europe
d'ailleurs comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer le comprendre
écoutez pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est l'histoire de ce sous
variant omicron à b2 qui semble
prévalant au danemark d'ailleurs autres
pays où l'épidémie ne régresse pas et
puis surtout le fait que et bien il y a
une certaine hétérogénéité du début de
la vague omicron et probablement des
chaînes de contamination dans le pays
ainsi par exemple en ile de france et en
corse l'épidémie a déjà atteint son pic
et semble régresser certes lentement
mais dans d'autres régions notamment en
zone rhône alpes l'épidémie continue à
progresser et donc évidemment il faut
poursuivre les mesures barrières pour
limiter les contaminations et un nombre
de décès est également plus important
pour pourquoi se piquer ces derniers
jours
alors comme vous le savez les décès sont
toujours décalé par rapport aux
contaminations et par rapport aux
admissions à l'hôpital est en
réanimation donc aujourd'hui l'essentiel
des décès touchent les personnes qui ont
été admis en réanimation pour des
infections liées aux variantes delta ce
sont donc des personnes qui ont été
infectées il ya longtemps déjà et qui
malheureusement malgré une prise en
charge optimale à l'hôpital est en
réanimation se trouve dans une situation
extrêmement grave et finissent par
décéder il faut à gauche ajoutez à ce
sous groupe principal un autre groupe de
patients qui sont des patients très âgés
des patients immunodéprimés des patients
avec de lourdes comorbidités non
vaccinés qui touchés y compris par le
variant omicron malheureusement font des
formes graves et en raison de leur état
général sont généralement pas admis en
réanimation et 17 de façon précoce par
rapport à leur contamination alors jean
françois delfraissy lui prédit une
amélioration à la mi mars et ce qui se
dessine selon vous
alors évidemment aujourd'hui nous
n'avons toujours pas atteint le pic des
contaminations en france il est probable
que celui-ci puisse être observé dans
les jours qui viennent mais il est
toujours pas là nous ne savons pas
d'ailleurs quand est ce qu'il va être
observée et comme vous le savez les
hospitalisations sont toujours décalé de
7 à 10 jours par rapport aux
contaminations et les décès décalé
davantage donc de fait et bien
l'épidémie va continuer à sévir même si
l'on envisage rythme de reflux
relativement important avec peut-être
une baisse de moitié des cas de
contaminations chaque semaine le nombre
de contaminations roos restera encore
extrêmement élevé pendant tout le mois
de février avec une saturation des
services d'hospitalisation et même de
réanimation jusqu'à la début mars donc
effectivement il faut être prudent sans
compter le fait qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons aucune certitude concernant
l'émergence éventuelle d'un nouveau
variant qui pourrait nous arriver
des pays sous vacciner peut-être en un
mot pour conclure la situation justement
aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
écoutez la situation est quand même sous
contrôle il faut pas non plus à l'armée
tout le monde le nombre de patients
admis pour qu'ovide est relativement
important mais il faut savoir qu'il ya
deux catégories de patients les patients
qui ont une forme plots munich grave
decaux vide
qui représente à peu près deux tiers à
trois quarts de ces patients et les
patients qui ont ce que l'on appelle une
copie d'accessoires c'est à dire qu'ils
sont contaminés par omicron mais qui
sont hospitalisés pour d'autres raisons
même si leur hospitalisation n'a rien à
voir avec l'aco vide elle complique
quand même la prise en charge sont des
patients qui doivent aller dans des
secteurs dédiés avec un personnel qui
doit prendre des mesures de précaution
donc de fait le nombre de patients
contaminés par la copie 19 et tout
augmente toujours en hospitalisation
conventionnelles notamment avec environ
2500 nouveaux entrants par jour et
aujourd'hui trente mille patients
hospitalisés mais il est vrai qu'un
quart de ses patients finalement n'ont
rien à voir avec la commune merci
beaucoup bruno megaman pour votre
éclairage sur rt frange rappel vous êtes
chefs de service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière